like to play a quick roundup
truth or dare
um okay we have uh liam charleston here
um hello hi hello
hi
hi liam hello lovely to meet you all oh
yeah
i promise it's not fake where are you
from i'm from melbourne in australia
all right what's it gonna be a drew or a
dare mine is a dare today oh
uh so back home in australia i'm a
teacher and i love playing this game
with my students we love you on your
just in front of you there there is two
bowls so using the straw i challenge you
to try and move the candy from one bowl
to the other using only the straw and
the challenge is you only have 30
seconds so you've all got to try and
beat each other and we're going to put a
little friendly wager on this if that's
okay oh no what is it all right we're
gonna uh divide up with the audience
robin will go on the left okay and uh
ross will go on the right thank you hi
and i am lucky enough to have our front
section come in our club chairs um and
whatever whoever wins that part of the
audience is going to go home with a
treat
[Applause]
everyone
ready oh my god
[Applause]
oh
[Applause]
oh my god sorry did i do it we all did
really good
and yours looks like i don't know we got
a counter we count them okay
i might
shoot i might have that no i think you
won you did great okay ready
i'm so light-headed two
four
whoops
i think you won
i don't know yours looks way fuller than
mine 19 yeah you won how did i win if we
both have 19 we tie how many do you have
less than 19.
[Applause]
wow all right everybody we've got our
club chairs
and um the left side but
we can't do that to you everybody's
gonna go home
because our friends at zolly candy are
the best in every single one of our
audience members is going home with a
delicious candy bundle from zoli candy
thank you
so much i'm so busy
i'm so dizzy
um cheers you guys cheers
a third season of a black lady sketch
show premieres tonight
[Applause]
[Music]
you